from Leonardo DiCaprio and hey that's
not Scorsese comes a production and put
the cast through physical and mental
torture to film and put the audience
through two and a half hours of mild
boredom to watch
yep that's the sky yep it's still the
sky oh look there's the sky again skies
not going anywhere
another sky shot oh goodie oh look at
that it's the sky again this is put the
camera down forget it was rolling and
sky the revenant after decades of losing
to his contemporaries Matthew
McConaughey Forest Whitaker in the last
year Jamie Foxx and watch Leo literally
scratch and claw his way to an Academy
Award as he stacks the deck in this epic
Oscar bait featuring a true story about
a historical figure plus a son he never
had
and a poetic ending where he finally
gets the revenge the real guy never had
shot by last year's Best Picture Best
Director and Best Cinematography winners
and released and here we're his biggest
competition was this more than quick lab
let's sell this little beauty and split
the take 5050 seriously if he lost a
communist Heisenberg we'd riot dive into
a beautiful film that isn't half as
interesting as it's making of story that
will have audiences wondering where in
eure to hit the cuts and it's amazing
tracking shots questioning what elements
were real and what were CGI and
marveling at the use of natural lighting
because they sure as hell won't be
caught up in the narrative yes thank you
we know the sky is still there in the
grand tradition of nel and Pootie Tang
what it's I prepare for two powerhouse
performances you won't be able to
understand as Leo shows his full range
of emotional grunting while Tom Hardy
mumbles about pelts we're not going no
campaign held avail you're 30 palp fail
you already lost my shirt else UMP else
we collected Oh still outdoor pal thrill
as leo blurs the line between actor and
role as you watch him actually endure
the freezing cold get inside a dead
horse and eat raw fish and bison liver
which is cool and all but doesn't being
good at acting mean you're good at
pretending to do things
I mean I'd borrow a real liver - just
saying so like where's my Oscar so
prepare for a lot of slow shots of
pretty landscapes mixed with the
occasional bursts of extreme violence to
wake you up that will shock you then
bore you then we'll get so over the top
it's one music change away from becoming
jackass
come on
Oh
starring Academy Award winner Leonardo
DiCaprio Oh feels so good to say that
sad max domhnall gleeson yes
nailed it hey eyebrows came for Maze
Runner and sexual harassment grisly Q
glass and the terrible horrible no good
very bad day yeah I know Leo went
through a lot for this role but look at
the haircut on Mark Ruffalo and
spotlight now that's acting be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers throw
the cheese you are my number one guy it
works 100% of the time every time it
works I'm of a mind to make some Mookie
kneel before Zod pee in a jar and call
it granny's peach Dee